a very warm welcome to all of yours
this is Angela from simply learned and
today we will dive into a tutorial on
the configuration management tool chef
so if you look at the DevOps approach or
the DevOps lifecycle you will see that
chef falls under operations and
deployment so before we begin let's have
a brief look at all that you learn today
first we'll get to know why should be
your chef and what exactly is the chef
two of the most common terms used with
chef configuration management and
infrastructure as code we'll have a
brief look at these we'll also have a
look at the confidence of chef and the
chef architecture quickly goes through
the various flavors of Chef and finally
we will wrap it up with a demo a demo on
the installation of Apache on our nodes
so let's begin guys why should we use
chef well consider a large company now
this company caters to a large number of
clients and provides a number of
services or solutions of course to get
all of this done they need a huge number
of servers and a huge number of systems
basically they will have a huge
infrastructure now this infrastructure
needs to be continuously configured and
maintained in fact when you're dealing
with an infrastructure that size there's
a good chance systems may be failing and
in the long run as your company expands
new systems may even get added so what
do you do well you could say the company
has the best system administrator out
there but all by himself could he
possibly take care of an infrastructure
that size no he can't and that's where
chef comes in cuz chef automates this
entire process so what does chef provide
chef provides continuous deployment so
when you look at the market space today
you see how products and their updates
are coming out in a matter of days so
it's very important that a company is
able to deploy the product the minute
it's ready so that once it's out it's
not already obsolete chef also provides
increased system robustness as we saw
chef can automate the infrastructure but
in spite of this automation there's a
good possibility that errors do creep in
chef can detect all these bugs and
remove them before deploying them into
the real environment not only this chef
also adapts to the cloud
we all know how today the services tools
solutions everything is revolving around
the cloud so chef does really play along
by making itself easily integrate able
with the cloud platform so now that you
know why to you chef let's look at what
exactly a chef chef is an open source
tool developed by ops code of course
there are paid versions of Chef such a
chef enterprise but other than that most
of it is freely accessible chef is
written in Ruby and Ella if you would
have gone through any previous material
on chef I'm sure you would have come
across Ruby being related to chef but
not Erlang so this is why coz Ruby and
err Lang are both used to build chef but
when it comes to actually writing the
codes in chef it's just Ruby and these
are the codes that's deployed onto your
multiple servers and does the automatic
configuration and maintenance and this
is why chef is a configuration
management tool so I've used this term
configuration management a couple of
times what exactly does this mean let's
start with the definition of
configuration management configuration
management is a collection of
engineering practices that provides a
systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment so let's break this
down configuration management basically
is a collection of practices and one of
these practices for these practices are
for managing your entities the entities
which are required for efficient
deployment so what are these entities
that you need for efficient deployment
they are code infrastructure and people
code is basically the code the system
administrators write for configuring
your various systems infrastructure is
the collection of your systems and your
servers and then finally you have the
teams that take care of this
infrastructure so cords need to be
updated whenever your introduction needs
a new configuration or some sort of
updation in the operating system or the
software versions your code needs to be
updated at first and as the requirements
of the company change the
infrastructures configuration needs to
change and finally of course the people
need coordination so if you have a team
of system administrators and say person
a
make some change to the code person B C
D and so on you need to be well aware
when the change is made as to why it was
made what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so there
are two types of configuration
management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your nodes pushes these files onto the
node so the complete control lies with
the server on your right side we have
the pull configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pull against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files chef follows pull
configuration and how it does this
we'll see further in our video another
important term often used with chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's Tim Tims a system
administrator at large company now he
receives a task he has to set up a
server and he has to install 20 software
applications over it so he begins he
sets up the server but then it hits him
it would take him the entire night to
install 20 software applications wooden
things have been much simpler if he just
had a code to do so well of course codes
do make things much simpler codes have a
number of advantages they easily
modifiable so if today Tim is told we
need Maya skill installed on 20 systems
Tim simply writes a code to do so and
the very next day Tim is told we changed
our mind
we don't need Maya skill I think we'll
just use Oracle this is not bothered him
because now he just opens the file he
makes a few Corrections in his code and
that should work just fine code is also
testable so if Tim had to write 10
commands to do something and at his
tenth command he realized the very first
command he wrote there was something not
right there well that would be quite
tiresome wouldn't it with codes however
you can test it even before running it
and all the bugs can be caught and
corrected codes are also deployables so
they're easy
deplorable and they're deployed multiple
times so now that we saw the various
advantages of having codes let's say in
what infrastructure as code exactly is
here's the definition infrastructure as
code is a type of IT infrastructure
where the operation team manages the
code rather than a manual procedure so
infrastructure as a code allows the
operations team to take care of a code
which automatically performs various
procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your nodes now these codes
which in case of chef are written in
Ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command-line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
nodes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final confidence the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes or high
is a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required chef client is
a
such service on your node which is
responsible for all the communications
with the server
so whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift line is responsible for
communicating this demand to the server
since you have a number of nodes in a
chef architecture it's not necessary
that each node is identical so of course
every node can have a different
configuration let's now have a look at
the chef's architecture so here we have
a workstation one servo machine and two
nodes you can have any number of nodes
first things first
the system administrator must create a
recipe so the recipes that are mentioned
in our chef architecture are just dummy
recipes we look into actual functioning
recipes later in our demo so you have
one recipe two recipes three recipes and
a collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
source you have simply learn three dot
GRB e RB is the extension for your Ruby
files so the cookbooks are only created
at the workstation they now need to be
sent over to the server where they are
stored and this is the task of the knife
knife is a command-line tool which is
responsible for transferring or your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife uploads simply
dashdb
we're simply dashdb is the name of the
cookbook we then move on to our node
machines at a nodes we run the Ojai
service the Ojai service will collect
all information regarding the current
state of your nodes and send it over to
the chef client when you run the shift
lined these informations are sent over
to the server and they are tested
against the cookbooks so if there is any
discrepancy between the current state of
your nodes and the cookbook that is if
one of the nodes does not match the
configurations required the cookbook is
then fetched from the server and
executed at the node this sets the node
to the right state there are various
flavors of chef we'll quickly go through
these first we have chef solo with chef
solo there's no separate server so your
cookbooks are located on the node itself
now this kind of configuration is used
only when you have just a single node to
take care of
the next flavor is a hosted chef with
hosted chef
you still have your workstation and your
note but your server is now used as a
service on the cloud this really makes
things simple because you don't have to
set up a server yourself and it still
performs all the functioning of a
typical chef this is the configuration
you will notice that we'll be using in
our demo chef client server with chef
line server you have a workstation you
have server and you have n number of
nodes now this is the traditional chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private chef private
chef is also known as enterprise chef in
this case your workstation server and
known all are located within the
enterprise infrastructure this is the
main difference between chef client
server and private chef in case of chef
client server all these three machines
could be dispersed the enterprise
version of chef also provides the
liberty to add extra layers of security
and other features and we reach the
final part of our video where we'll have
the hands-on so before we dive into a
demo let me just quickly give you an
introduction to it we'll be using 2
virtual boxes both sent os7 one will be
used as workstation while the other will
be a node so we are just using one node
to make things simple the server will be
used as a service on the cloud now these
are the steps will be performing during
our demo we'll first download and
install the chef TK on our workstation
we then make an empty cookbook file and
we'll write a recipe into it we need to
then set up the server so as I mentioned
earlier server will be a service on the
cloud so you'll have to create a profile
but this will be completely free we then
link the workstation to the server and
we'll upload the recipe to the server
the nodes will now download the
cookbooks from the server and configure
themselves so now that you have some
idea about what we'll be doing let's
move on to the actual demo we began our
demo here's my Oracle VM VirtualBox
manager I have two machines here I've
already created my workstation and node
both of these are sent to as seven
machines just for you to differentiate
this is my terminal and for my
workstation
it's a black background with white text
and as of my note it's a black
background with green text the first
thing you do is you go to your
workstation books and open a web browser
search for chef DK installation go to
the first link which is your ships
official page and under Red Hat
Enterprise because our systems a Red Hat
system select the link of the version
that you're using so I'm using Center at
7 so my operating system version is 7 so
I'll take this link now this is the link
for downloading your chef DK you copy
this link and go to your terminal guys
notice I'm in the home directory of my
root user so let install our chef DK
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and shall Takei's downloaded next step
we need to install it
and this is the version of the chef DK
that we have downloaded so type the same
you
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks
so first let's make a chef repository so
within that we'll have a folder for
holding all our cookbooks and within a
cookbook we'll write our recipe so we
start with the directory for chef
repository move into it create a folder
called cookbooks within which we'll
stored each of our cookbooks move into
this folder
[Music]
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our chef DK we
have a chef repo folder here and let's
check the contents of the chef repo and
this has cookbooks okay so our first
cookbook that will be making will be
under this folder cookbooks so let's
move into cookbooks
we are in now we need to create a first
cookbook so the instruction for creating
your first cookbook is chef generate
cookbook and the name of your cookbooks
I'm just giving the name a sample
yeah so our cookbook sample is created
now when you create your cookbook you'll
notice that a hierarchy is also
automatically created so let's just
check the hierarchy of a cookbook let's
move into sample and tree this is a
command for checking the hierarchy so
here as you can see we have recipes and
under recipes we have default dot RB
so we'll be editing this default dot RB
to create RSP ok so let's begin with
that let's move into our recipes folder
and open your default dot RB
and here we are so now we will type in
our code
so what are SP for a recipes for
installing the httpd package on our node
and then we'll also create a small index
file where we just have a simple content
such as welcome or something like that
just to check if I had GT TPD is working
fine so let's begin typing the code here
package httpd service httpd do and what
must be done with this package is that
once it's installed it needs to be
enabled and it needs to be started and
so that's our first task our next task
is creating our HTML file so as you know
all your HTML files will follow this
path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully configured your
note
and that's it that's a simple quote so
our recipe is now ready save it and exit
back to your terminal now what we need
to do is that we need to configure our
server so go to your browser on the
search engine type manage dot chef dot
IO so as I mentioned earlier we'll be
using a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your login page for the
chef server most of you may not have a
profile already so you go to click here
to get started and fill in the details
it's just like creating an account on
Facebook so I already have my accounts
I've put in the credentials here I'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in is you'll get an option to
create an organization so all you have
to do there is you gotta enter the name
of your organization and just below that
there's another box for entering a short
form of your organization now my
organisation name was simply learn and
the short form was SLP one two three so
when you come to the administration tab
under organisation you can see this
organization name next step click on
this arrow and you got a download your
starter kit ok so once you click on down
starter kit you will come to this page
where there is a button for download
starter kit so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal so you
come back to your terminal and next what
you need to do is you need to unzip your
chef started or zip so for that first
we'll move our chef starter to the root
so it's currently present under the
Downloads folder let's move it
so we have moved our chefs started or
zip now let's unzip it first let's just
check the contents of our route directly
right now so we have a chef depository
chef repo by a folder that we created
the chef's starter zip that we just
moved and of course the chef DK so now
we can unzip our chef starter kit and
that's done so our next step we got to
move the chef starters dot zip file into
our cookbooks which lies inside the chef
repository this is done because we'll be
executing our further commands to
connect our workstation with the server
from the cookbooks because that is where
our sample cookbook is and that's moved
so now we'll run a knife command so what
knife does is that it uploads your dress
piece or your cookbooks onto the server
so here's the command for running your
nice
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and uploading sample
zero point one point zero and uploading
sample yeah so our cookbook is uploaded
now let's just check this at our server
how we do that is go back to your
browser where you have opened your
server so there's no node here yet
because we have not configured our node
with the server but we have configured
our workstation with the server and you
see here our cookbooks uploaded sample
so a workstation and our server are
connected so now we need to connect our
node with the server so first we move on
to unknown machine
we need to take the IP address of a node
machine so for the IP address will just
type if config
[Music]
right so this is your IP address
192.168.1.1 stun go back to your
workstation I'll just keep it this way
so I can see both okay go back to your
workstations terminal but this time to
connect our server with the node so we
have taken the IP of our node and this
is where we will be using it one ninety
two point one sixty eight point two
point the username which is root in our
case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular note on our server I'm
just giving it chef node you can give it
whatever you like we'll just check the
command knife bootstrap the IP address
is a chooser a user which is root SSH
password the password for the root and
finally the node name
and the Nords getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server we'll go back to a browser open
our server service on the cloud and we
check the node tab so ideally your node
name should appear there
drift so our node is added also if you
notice here a chef client service on the
node has started running so let's just
check this with the server
good your notes and here we go
so chef node a center a7 platform this
is our IP so it's all done so now we
need to add a cookbook to the run list
of this node so come here click on this
arrow edit run list here sample this is
the cookbook that we want to run on a
node put on the current run list and
here we have the run button just click
on that so this should have transferred
our cookbook on to the node let's check
that go to your node machine
clear this we need to be the route let's
run the chef client service
so we are running at once again because
after it was started we did add
something to our run list the changes in
the run list is updated
so in one minute 56 seconds a cookbook
has run on a note so the configuration
changes should have been made let's
check that it's pretty simple just go to
your browser on the search engine just
type localhost
and here's a HTML page that we created
on our workstation Congrats you
configured your first note and I really
hope you did so that is the end of our
demo we have successfully installed the
httpd package on our node and we have
also executed a HTML file so with that
we come to an end to our video now let's
have a quick look at everything you
learn today first you saw why you should
probably use chef then what exactly is
the chef we looked into the two most
important terms often used with chef
configuration management and
infrastructure as code we also saw the
various components of chef and how these
components work together to provide the
capabilities that chef does we looked
into the four flavors or chef and
finally we wrapped it up with the demo
on installing httpd package on our node
and also writing a simple HTML file so I
hope you guys really liked the video if
you did please do hit the like button
also subscribe to our channel if you
have not yet because we have a lot of
good stuff coming up this is Angela
signing off thank you hi there if you
liked this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here